hi there this is steve kaufman i'm not
at home i'm uh on holiday
uh i had two weeks in china
magnificent weeks
my country's just amazing the amount of
construction
somebody said that the national bird of
china is the construction crane crane
get it bird crane you just see
construction cranes everywhere
the density of construction in
even smaller towns
the i traveled on the high-speed train
it's magnificent there's phenomenal
radio rail stations in every
town it it just blows the mind and
for someone who lived there
or at least didn't live there but
visited there in the late 60s early 70s
to see what's happening in china today
is just beyond belief
and of course it all started to happen
insofar as economic growth was concerned
once the um
you know the
free action of the market once private
initiative was allowed to uh
to
participate in the in economic activity
in china prior to that they had
all kinds of public
uh initiatives mass mobilization of the
people
based on whatever
theory
was popular with the government at that
time the government made all the
decisions
um
and so people are mobilized with spades
to go and dig
lengthy you know irrigation ditches that
may or may not have been useful
um
backyard
furnaces and whatever they did i can't
remember but the net result was a lot of
wasted energy wasted resources suffering
people dying unnecessarily and so forth
and uh in the last uh
30 years the country has just progressed
economically
tremendously now it has created a lot of
inequality in the country and i think
that's something they're trying to
address now
but it has created tremendous wealth
tremendous wealth
so many people are well off well to do
sitting in the train with people who
they've all got ipads the people that
i'm sitting with now of course there are
very poor people who are working largely
on piecework 14 hours a day but there no
one's complaining that i can see they're
all working very hard to try and and and
improve their lot and so you take 1.3
billion people or a large number of them
working very very hard
and you have a tremendous economic
engine
but i was thinking about this whole
issue of public and private
because we have a tremendous crisis now
in in the western world
where we have countries that have
enormous debt
and
public sectors that are feel they are
entitled to
um
you know as a as almost like a
birthright
to certain uh conditions of work and
compensation
and uh
by the same token people want to avoid
paying taxes in some countries i guess
particularly in places like greece
but uh countries and and in italy and
and elsewhere but also in the united
states and so forth countries have
been running these enormous enormous
deficits
so i don't know in detail how
useful a lot of public expenditure is
it's it's certainly true that it's hard
to argue against things like
you know publicly like that
the whole society pays for medical care
the whole society pays for health care
for for education that we have public
parks public facilities that all these
things are available free of charge even
that the medical system is available
free of charge it's a very popular idea
i myself like the idea that we have
public facilities that we can use
without having to pay for that's a great
idea
if we can afford them
the the problem is that the size of
government and the the
and of course i was just looking at our
own situation where i live in vancouver
in our municipal government in west
vancouver 80 percent of the cost is in
wages
the wage package and the compensation
package that those people have is much
higher than the corresponding level in
the private sector
uh the size of our local government has
grown
by 40 percent in the last eight or nine
years when inflation has been very low
i don't think any citizens are aware of
any improvement in services
but
these organizations just naturally grow
they feel have to do this they have to
hire that person this person it all
grows
if i look at
language education for immigrants
which costs canada about a billion
dollars a year sort of instruction in
the official languages primarily for
immigrants but also this uh
i mean i recently read in the paper that
a senior bureaucrat was appointed to
some position
and uh he was in his 50s i guess and and
so the government decided that he was
going to get
one or two years of full-time french
instruction
uh the man probably earns well over a
hundred thousand dollars he's going to
earn his salary and he's going to have
full-time
language instruction in this particular
article i read in the paper
it said that
uh you know language instruction you
know intensive language instruction can
cost up to a hundred thousand dollars a
year in auto i mean that's absolutely
mind-blowing
uh a high percentage of people within
the civil service who take these
language courses in french never ever
end up using the language
but if i get back to the immigrants i
ask myself the question if there were no
if there was no government-supported
language instruction for immigrants what
what would happen would there be any
difference
i think that there wouldn't be much
difference
in terms of
the uh
you know rate at which immigrants learn
english or french i mean let that ring
um
those immigrants
now who want to learn
they learn
they find a way to learn and if you're
living in canada let's say if you're
living in vancouver you have the radio
you have television you have newspapers
uh you have all the resources that are
available on the internet for learning
languages you can go buy a book you can
go to the library you can borrow
materials you can borrow rosetta stone
there's so much available if you're
motivated to learn not to mention just
talking to people
people who are not motivated motivated
to learn won't learn so you can send
them to school and we see them now the
immigrants gather
you know every morning for their two
hour class
uh and then go back home and spend the
rest of the day in their native language
and they don't learn
so i'm quite convinced that
if immigrants were told language
improvement is your own responsibility
you have to do it maybe even held out
some
you know competition or reward but even
without that just tell them it's your
job to do it
we expect you to do it but
you no one can help you you have to do
it on your own you have to want to do it
if you want to do it you can do it if
you don't want to do it you aren't going
to be able to do it whether you go to
school or not
i think
that there would be
little difference in outcomes
that all of the money we spend on
schools in this public education uh of
immigrants in the official languages in
canada
is
largely
a waste of money
that
it's not a waste of money in the sense
that there are teachers earning salaries
from this but in terms of the net effect
in terms of the number of people who
come to canada and who learn to speak
english well or french
i don't think it has much impact and i'd
be very interested to hear your opinion
and i'm sure that most people don't
agree with me so
look forward to hearing from you bye for
now